Okay, good morning. So, welcome to the
first class of the second semester.
This semester, we are going to build on
what we've learned the first semester
um to better understand human history
and to better understand what's
happening in the world today.
And also to be able to predict the
future.
Okay? So, if you have been following
current events, and I hope you have,
there are now three
major conflicts
in the world.
The first
and most devastating is the war in
Ukraine
where Russia and Ukraine have been
conflict
uh
for about 3 years now, and a lot of
people have died.
Um there's controversy over the exact
number,
but
um
it's possible that over a million
soldiers have died in this war so far.
And even though
President Donald Trump of the United
States
has
shown signs that he wants to end the
war,
we don't really know
when the war will end.
Okay? So, this war in in Ukraine, it is
still happening, and it's affecting
everything and everyone
because
um obviously brings a lot of instability
and uncertainty uncertainty in the
world, but it's also driving up prices,
and it's making things inconvenient. So,
when you fly to the United States,
you'll discover that it takes you longer
to fly to the United States because you
can't fly through Russia. You have to
fly around Russia, okay?
So, that's the first major conflict.
The second conflict
um which is not as deadly
but which will probably prove to be even
more dangerous is the war in the Middle
East, the conflict in the Middle East.
Um, as you know, um, for the past couple
years Israel has been in conflict with
basically
most of its neighbors.
It's launched an expedition into the
Gaza Strip
and Hamas
for what Hamas did on October 7th.
Um, it's launched war a war against
Lebanon. It's involved in Syria.
And
the signs tell us
that this conflict
will spread.
Trump has come in and promised
um, a resolution to the conflict.
But as I will show you this semester,
there are historical structural forces
that make this conflict possibly the
beginning of World War III.
This conflict will only increase. The
great fear right now is
Israel attacks Iran
and drives the United States into war
with Iraq.
And this will mark the beginning of
World War III.
And this could possibly lead to the end
of the world as we know it today.
If the United States attacks Iran
both Russia and China must intervene
in some capacity.
Does that make sense to you guys?
Iran right now, it's the linchpin of the
global economy.
The first reason is there's a lot of oil
in Iran in the Middle East.
And China, South Korea, and Japan
get most of its oil from the Middle
East, right? So, if you if the oil
supply is cut off, then the Chinese
economy, the South Korean economy, the
Japanese economy, basically all of East
Asia
faces economic collapse and catastrophe.
Okay?
But second is if you look at a map,
Iran is really the center of the world.
Meaning most of the world's trade goes
through that area, especially something
called the Strait of Hormuz.
Iran has a capacity
uh to cut off all trade
in the Strait of Hormuz.
And that would be catastrophe for the
global economy.
And if that were to happen,
then
the Western powers would need to get
involved in order to free up the Strait
of Hormuz.
And then Russia, India, China, who
knows? Okay, but a lot of people would
have have to get involved in order to
protect their economic interests.
All right?
So, um I will go this mess I will go
into the semester.
We'll talk a lot about what's driving
conflict in Middle East.
There are these geopolitical
factors as I
as I discussed, but there are all also
these religious factors that we looked
into a bit
um last semester, but I will explain
more this semester.
Okay?
And then the third and final conflict
um is basically
the United States against the world.
What I mean by that is
that um ever since collapse of the
Soviet Union, the fall of the Berlin
Wall in 1991,
we have been living in
something called a unipolar
moment. Meaning there's only one
hegemon, one superpower.
And as such, the United States has been
able to
dictate
policy, especially economic policy,
around the world.
United States controls all trade. We
have to use the US dollar in order to
trade. The The United States also uses
its military to protect shipping lanes.
And this is a criticism called the Pax
Americana, the American peace. And this
of course has brought tremendous
prosperity to to the world.
Okay, China would not have grown as fast
as China did without the Pax Americana.
It is American ships,
American warships, that allowed Chinese
ships to sail safely around the world to
deliver goods around the world.
But this unipolar moment has also
created a lot of conflict.
The main conflict being the United
States can
can invade any country for no reason.
2003, it invaded Iraq for no reason.
It destroyed Libya for no reason.
It almost destroyed Syria for no reason.
Okay? So, the number of countries the
United States has gone and destroyed are
just staggering.
So, and that's why Russia under Putin,
because it felt being it felt bullied,
uh, it felt disrespected, that's why
Russia is now in conflict with the
United States.
And strangely enough, this conflict has
caused the United States to go into
conflict with
the rest of the world, okay? So, as you
may know, United States right now under
Trump has declared or is about to launch
trade wars against a lot of countries.
Canada,
Mexico,
quite possibly, very quickly, that's the
European Union.
And the United States is is already at
economic war with Russia and China.
Okay? So, we will go in this mess. We
will also discuss this this semester why
this is happening.
Again, my argument to you is that if you
know enough history,
if you if you study the historical
structural forces that drive
um
global conflict,
then you'll understand what's going on.
And you'll also be able to predict
what will happen.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay.
So,
um what I want to talk today is about a
new model of historical analysis.
How can we understand the movement of
history? Why do people do what they do?
Why do nations go to war? Why do nations
have peace?
Okay? So, I'm looking at grand history.
I'm looking at the
uh large structural movement of history.
And
in the past, there have been two
main models for understanding historical
development.
Okay? So, the first
is the idea of a cycle or a circle.
And this makes sense, right? Because
this mirrors what we experience in life.
When we we are born, but then we die.
And then other people are born, and then
they die. Okay? So, it's a cycle. You
look at the seasons. There's um winter,
but that gives rise to spring, which
then gives rise to summer, then the
fall, then winter again. It's a cycle.
Okay? So, throughout most of human
history,
most people have understood the movement
of the world as a cycle. This is
certainly true in Chinese history,
right?
Um
dynasties
rise because because they have the
mandate of heaven.
Heaven favors them.
And they do justice when they first
arise, but over time, for a variety of
reasons, because of corruption, because
there's a there's a bad emperor,
they lose mandate of heaven, which
allows
a rebellion,
which then creates a new dynasty.
So, it's a
So, Chinese history is almost a
continuous cycle
of dynastic rise and decline.
Okay? Now,
in the in the Western context, there's
also a cycle. There are many different
cycles, but let me explain one cycle
that we've noticed
in the Greek and Roman world.
The cycle is this.
There are three major
factions in a society.
There is the people.
There is nobility.
And then there is the king
or a great person.
Okay? And each of these factions have a
particular strength.
The people, their strength comes from
their numbers.
Right?
They have mass.
The nobility, um is only minority
people, but they have authority.
They're respected.
Because they know
uh more, they have they are better at
war than ordinary people, but they have
authority, okay? People respect them.
And the king
has the army.
Okay?
So, these are the three major forces or
factions in a society.
And these three factions are always in
conflict.
And what happens is a changing alliance,
where
the two of the three get together to
beat one.
Okay?
And then this forces a new alliance,
right? So, what happens is this.
You first have
something called a oligarchy,
where the nobility is in charge, and
everyone has to do what they do what
what they command.
Okay? But over time, this oligarchy
becomes corrupt.
And the and the The the way they become
corrupt is by
exploiting the people through debt.
All right? So, in a nobility, the nobles
own the land, you have to work the land,
but you get a share.
And that's fine.
But sometimes the weather is bad.
So, you can't
work the land, you can't pay me the
rent. So, I give you a loan.
And over time, this loan becomes a debt.
And at a certain point, you can't pay
off the debt. So, what happens? You
become a slave.
And your children become my my slave as
well.
Okay? So, this creates a lot of conflict
in society.
How is this conflict resolved?
Because one of the nobility
wants to be king. And he And he sees an
opportunity
in the civil conflict between the people
and the
and the nobility.
Okay?
So, he tells the people, "If you make me
king,
I will clear your debts."
And this creates a monarchy.
And the first king is usually a good
king because he had to work hard to
obtain his position.
And
um people love him for the fact that he
cleared away their debts.
This This is what we call a jubilee, by
the way. The word is jubilee. And this
happens a lot in human history.
But the problem is the king has a son
who's not so good.
And then the son has a son who's awful,
okay?
And so, the nobility get angry, the
people get angry, and they rebel.
And they create a democracy.
Okay?
But then in the democracy, because what
happens in a democracy is it's the best
people
or the best speakers, the wealthiest
people, who control the votes.
And so, they get together. And what do
they do? They And what do they do? They
create an oligarchy.
Okay? Do you Do you see how the how the
cycle works? And this cycle goes on and
on and on.
These
um three factions always in conflict
with each other.
And their And
the way they form their alliances
creates a certain form of government,
okay? When
the nobility's in charge is an
oligarchic oligarchy. When But then
a king and the people work together or
throw in a creative monarchy.
And then they
And the king becomes corrupt, and so the
nobility and the people work together
create a democracy.
Okay?
And you can see the cycle happening
today in the United States as well,
right? Because who is Trump?
Trump is a king.
Does that make sense to you guys? What
is king What What is Trump saying? Trump
is saying to the people, "The elite are
corrupt. The elite are stealing from
you. The elite are lying to you.
Vote for me, and I will destroy the
elite, and I will give you more economic
opportunities." Okay? Do you understand?
So, this is a really important idea.
Trump is not going to be president for 4
years. His ambition is to be
king.
Okay? And we see this cycle throughout
human history.
So, that's the idea of a cycle.
All right?
We also have another model
of human history develop of human
historical development, which is a line,
okay? A line. And the idea of progress
towards truth.
Okay? So, that's the other competing
model. Okay, there are two main models.
There's a cycle, and then there's a
line.
And the idea of a line is human society
does not go on and on in a in a useless
cycle. It is moving towards a truth. It
is moving towards a good end.
Okay? So,
then this idea has been around for a
very long time. Remember in the Bible
the when King David first sponsored the
line of the Bible, the Bible was a line
where Yahweh the God he was looking for
a friend. He was looking for someone who
he could trust to rule his kingdom of
heaven.
And he first tried Adam and Eve
and they disobeyed him. Then he tried
Noah, then he tried Abraham,
and then he tried Moses, and then he
found his true friend who is David,
okay? So, the truth is David
in the Hebrew Bible.
Then you have the Romans.
Okay? Remember the Romans, Virgil wrote
something called the Aeneid.
And in the Aeneid um Troy was destroyed
so that Rome could be founded. And when
Rome was founded, Rome will have to
fight a series of wars that will
eventually lead to the rise of Augustus
Caesar.
And this will create something called
the Pax Romana.
And this is the end of history. This is
where all movement ends. Because once
you achieve the Pax Romana
there will be no more war.
Right? So, this idea of a line.
Obviously, this is not true. But back
then when they came up with this
history, they thought it was true.
And um if you know a little bit about
current history, then you'll know about
a man named Francis Fukuyama, who is an
American
who works for the government. And he
wrote something called The End of
History.
Which is an essay arguing
um that when the Soviet Union fell, it
showed the end of history.
Before history was a battle ideas.
Communism,
capitalism,
and now with the fall of the Soviet
Union, we now know
that Western liberal consumer democracy
is the best system in the world.
We no longer have to argue about this.
Everyone should try to be a liberal
consumer democracy, including China.
And if everyone became a consumer
liberal democracy, there would be no
more war.
We wouldn't want to fight because we're
too busy spending money.
And the best way to make money is
through trade, not war.
Okay? We all we we now also know this is
not true.
All right?
But the main
um
proponents of the line theory of
history, progress of history, are
actually Christians.
Okay? Christians. Why?
Because
they believe that Jesus marks a turning
point in history. And and at the And
when Jesus came, it marked a progress
towards truth. What is truth?
Truth is the second coming of Jesus.
Which will mark the end of the world.
When Jesus returns,
he will he will usher in a millennium, a
thousand years of peace.
When he will be king.
We will all have to obey him.
Okay? What I will show you in the
future, when we discuss Crusades, the
Crusades,
um is that
this idea, okay? It sounds like a simple
idea, but this idea is what's driving
a lot of conflict in the Middle East.
Believe it or not, but there are
millions of Christians. They're called
Christian Zionists, by the way,
who want war in the Middle East
because if there's war in the Middle
East and the world is about to end,
Jesus has to return from heaven to save
us.
Okay?
You think this is silly. You think this
is crazy. What I'm telling you right
now,
this idea, which millions of people
around the world believe in,
it's one of the main causes
of the war in the Middle East.
And guys,
crazy ideas
make crazy events.
All right?
So, there are people who literally
believe that we can save the world by
ending it.
It's only the threat of nuclear
holocaust. It's only the threat of the
end of Israel
that will force Jesus to return issuing
the second coming.
All right?
Now, what's important for us to
understand is that these are the two
basic frameworks of history.
But there are variations to these two
basic models, okay? So, for example,
Hegel. Okay? We'll We'll We'll discuss
Friedrich Hegel later on this semester.
He's He's really important. But he has
this idea called the dialectic.
The dialectic The Dialectic just means a
conflict, a conversation. So, what he
believes is that history is driven by
ideas that are in conflict with each
other.
Okay? Wherever there's an idea,
for example, let's just say you have
capitalism.
Then what will happen is a new idea
will arrive to challenge
the existing idea, what we'll call
communism, okay?
And then what will happen is these two
ideas will merge together
and they will draw on the best parts of
each other
and we can call this socialism.
All right? So, it's a line, okay? But
it's it's it's like this almost, right?
There's a idea There's There's a idea
Something comes in conflict and they and
this leads to a new idea, which then
leads to a new idea, okay? But he still
believes that we are progressing towards
the truth
through this conflict.
Right?
So, we'll discuss Hegel and his theory
of the dialectic
um later on in the semester. And this
will lead And this The idea of the
dialectic will lead to, of course,
Marxism. Okay? So, Marx is drawing a lot
on Hegel and another philosopher named
um Immanuel Kant for his theory of
communism.
But we'll do that in later on in the
semester.
All right? So, these are the two main
models of historical development. You
have the cycle, the his circle, or you
have the line.
You either believe that things move in
continuous motion
or they're moving towards an end.
Right? Does that make sense?
Any questions about these two models
so far?
Okay.
So,
what you will learn this semester is a
new model
of historical development.
Okay? It's a much more complicated model
than these two models, but I think it is
much more useful in helping us predict
the causes
of
um
historical development.
Okay?
Um
I want to argue why these two models
don't really work.
And it has to do with the fact that
history as an academic discipline is
just not very good.
It's just not.
What I mean by that is
you look at the world today, there's
this Trump presidency,
there's this conflict in the Ukraine,
there's the Middle East conflict, and
you would expect historians to come out
and say, "Oh, this has has happened
before, and we can then predict what
will happen, and so this is what's going
to happen, okay?"
But guess what, guys? They're not doing
that.
Also,
they're not very good at predicting
things. They're just not.
His history has is notorious
for not being able
for not being able to tell us much about
the future.
And they'll surely say, "Well, it's
because we look at the past."
And for me, this is frustrating because
if the history is any good, the history
is accurate,
then it should help us predict the
future, or or at least better understand
the present, okay?
So, the idea of truth, what is truth?
Well, truth does two things. First, it
explains.
Why did this happen? Why did World War
II start?
And the
answer we have today is like, "Hitler
was a bad guy. He was evil."
Okay, that doesn't explain much for us.
And then it also has to predict.
It predicts.
If it's truthful, then it predicts.
And history doesn't do that.
So,
I want to fix this problem by
introducing a new model
of history, which is a lot more
complicated, okay? I'll be honest with
you, it's a lot more complicated. But I
think for our purposes, it's more useful
at explaining why things happen the way
they do.
And it
helps us also predict
what will happen.
Okay? And this model is what I call
the oceanic currents of history.
Imagine the world as a huge ocean.
And within each ocean, there's an
ecosystem,
which has currents.
And then these currents come into
conflict with each other,
which leads to a new development. Okay?
So, think about hurricanes.
And the thing that's really important
about this model that I'm proposing is
there's no moral judgment in it.
Okay? I mean, obviously in a line, the
end where we're going is good and where
we're at now is bad.
Okay? But what I'm saying is
this moral judgment, saying this is
good, this is bad, it's not helpful. It
doesn't really tell us anything.
All right?
Okay. I'm much more interested in
explaining why this happened, how this
happened, and where this is going.
Okay. So,
let's look at the world
to understand this theory.
What I want What I will show you is the
world is divided into cultural
ecosystems. Okay? Cultural ecosystems.
This is a really important idea that you
you need to know for the rest of the
semester.
What I will argue is that culture is the
meta-reality.
Meta-reality.
So,
what's meta-reality?
Meta-reality is the understanding of the
world from which all other
understandings derive.
So, what I'm what I'm saying is that
culture is the most important part of
who you are.
Much more important than your gender,
much more important than your race,
ethnicity,
much more important
than your economic
demographic, okay? You're rich or poor.
Okay? So, to understand this idea why
culture is so important,
I will do a thought experiment.
Okay? A thought experiment. The thought
experiment is this.
Let's take a random guy from China
2,000 years ago, okay? Just a random
guy. We'll take him off the streets and
we'll put him into China today.
All right?
Now,
in 2,000 years, China has changed a lot,
right? We now have the internet. We have
computers.
We have cell phones. We have
skyscrapers. We have cars. We have
roads, okay? So, China has changed a lot
in 2,000 years.
How long would it take him for him to
adapt to the new China?
And my And I would say
I would say at most 5 to 10 years.
Because even though
on the surface,
China has changed a lot,
deep down inside,
China's culture has stayed consistent
for the past 3 to 4,000 years.
So, he will he will understand how to
make friends.
He will understand if he were to get a
job how to
uh associate with his boss and his
colleagues.
If he were to get the get to If he were
to get married, he would know how to
raise his children
to have them succeed in China. Okay,
does that make sense to you guys?
It would take him time to learn how to
use a cell phone and how to use a
computer
and how to drive a car,
but he can do so.
Does that make sense?
Now, let's do another experiment.
Let's take a random guy from China today
and put him in Germany
today.
Germany, okay?
What I will argue is this.
He will never ever
be able to adapt to the culture.
He may get a job as a pizza delivery
man, who knows, okay?
But he will never ever
make friends
who are German.
He won't find a German wife.
Whatever job he does, he won't know how
to succeed. He won't know what to say
to his boss. He won't know how to
associate with his boss. Okay, does that
make sense?
This is a guy who knows the internet,
who knows how to drive a car, who can
who can speak English,
but because of the culture,
he's always a stranger.
Does that make sense?
This first experiment, I hope, shows you
the persistence of culture. It's the
most important part of who you are.
It drives everything else.
It drives how you see the world. It
drives how you interact with others.
Okay?
So, what matters is the culture
and nothing else.
And what I'm what I what I want to show
you is
this semester
is the world can be divided into
cultural ecosystems because of the
history
because of the geography
because of the demographics, okay? Does
that make sense?
So, look,
Europe
is a cultural ecosystem.
All right, meaning someone from Germany
can go to Italy
and still feel at home.
They still They don't speak the same
language.
The geography is different, but they
share the same cultural orientation, the
same cultural values.
All right?
Someone who who lives in the Middle
East, okay? Well, so so somebody call
the Levant.
Israel and other places, okay? But
basically Middle East. That's also
another cultural ecosystem.
Then you have
um
uh the steppes.
All right, so remember the steppes are
this
grassland, this ocean of grassland that
basically extends from Hungary to
Mongolia, okay?
And then you have
um
China
India, okay? So, but they're different
these but they're these these different
ecosystems, cultural ecosystems that are
determined by their geography, their
history
and the demographics.
And culture is response
to geography, history, and demographics,
okay? Does that make sense?
All right?
Now, what I will show you is
that
within each ecosystem
they're always interacting with each
other,
okay? They're always interacting with
each other.
And when they change
they change their interaction with each
other. All right?
So
let's ask a really important question.
Which is why do empires
why do they fall, why do they decline,
why do they fail?
And this is a really important question.
How was it possible for the Roman Empire
to collapse?
How
were the Greeks able to defeat the
Persian Empire?
How were the Mongolians and the Manchu's
able to conquer the Chinese Empire?
All right? And what I will show you this
semester is
when this happens, when empires
conquered
the pattern is the same.
There's a consistent pattern in this.
All right?
So
let me explain the pattern. And then for
the semester we'll go into specific
instances of this pattern to explore the
um specifics, okay? Does that make
sense?
All right.
So what happens is this, why empires
fall is there's usually an empire, okay?
Let's just say Rome.
And as it expand they encounter
something called the borderlands.
They borderlands.
Borderlands are just places that are
um the intersections of empires.
Okay, so Mongolia is a borderland of the
Chinese Empire.
Right? Arabia is the borderland of the
Byzantine and the Sasanian Persian
Empires, okay?
And
the borderlands and the empire
become at first symbiotic.
Okay? Meaning they depend on each other.
They
they work with each other, okay? In
three ways.
The first and
the first most simple way that they
interact is through trade.
Okay? They trade with each other.
Second way they interact is through
um
military cooperation. So, what often
happens is the empire needs mercenaries.
And it turns out that people who live in
the borderlands make very good soldiers,
okay? Because they live in a time of war
and chaos. In the borderlands, there's
no central authority.
So, they're always fighting each other.
So, they make very good soldiers.
And then the third way they interact
with each other is
some
people in the borderlands will raid and
pillage the empire. They outfit the
empire for resources, okay?
So, they are interacting with each
other.
So, the pattern is this.
The borderlands first start off as maybe
as maybe an isolated region of the
world. So, Arabia,
uh the steppes,
uh and the Germanic north, okay? What we
call Scandinavia today, okay? The The
Norse The Norsemen.
So, these are all isolated parts. But as
the empire expands, they start to
interact
with these
isolated ecosystems.
And when they act we And when they
interact, what happens is
these borderlands become energized.
Okay? They It's like the empire's adding
fuel to the borderlands by giving them
more wealth, by giving them more
knowledge,
by giving them more access to
information. Okay, does that make sense?
And over time, what happens is
because of this new energy,
the borderlands become much more
populated, much more wealthy,
much more knowledgeable.
And then it creates internal conflicts
within their borderlands.
And the only way for them to to to
resolve this conflict is to expand.
Okay? They have to expand now. And in
the process of expan-
of expansion, what happens is
now and then they will conquer the
empire.
All right?
That's a pattern.
The borderlands are first these isolated
regions that no one knows much about.
They're like the stuff of legend and
myth.
When the empire expands,
it energizes this these borderlands. The
energy makes these borderlands more
wealthy, more populated,
and more militarily sophisticated.
That's creates conflicts within the
borderlands, too many people. So, what
are they forced to do? They're forced to
expand.
And during the course of this this
expansion, they come into conflict with
the empire. And now and then, they will
conquer the empire, become the new
empire.
That's a pattern. And it happens all
over human history.
Okay? This is This is how the Mongolians
conquered China. This is how the Manchus
conquered China.
Before the Mongolians and Manchus
conquered China, there was trade.
Uh Chinese the Chinese empire was using
them as mercenaries.
Okay? There was also a lot of small
conflict. Does that make sense?
All right.
So, now that I explained the pattern,
the question then is
why would this happen?
Why would this happen? How is it
possible for the borderlands, which
again is
only a fraction
of the wealth, the population, and the
resource of the empire.
How were they able to conquer the
empire?
And this is a really important lesson
you will learn
in this class, which is empires are
destined to collapse.
Empires
must collapse.
All right?
So, why is that the case?
In this class, you will learn there are
three boundary conditions of all
societies.
Eventually, all societies must collapse
for three reasons.
All right. The first reason is
elite overproduction.
Second reason is
rat utopia.
And the third reason is
um
uh financialism.
All right.
So, let me explain the first,
financialism. What do I What do I mean
by that? All right.
When a society first starts,
it's important for people to contribute
to its growth,
right? They can do that by starting a
farm.
When when I build a farm, I make goods.
I'm creating wealth for the society,
right?
You can also do that by building a
factory.
But over time, what happens is you
eventually realize that it's more
profitable for you to
lend money
than to build things.
Does that make sense?
It's as much profitable much easier for
you to
um
be a capitalist than it is to be an
entrepreneur
over time.
So, there's this very famous French
economist. His name is Thomas Piketty.
And he wrote a book called um Capital in
the 21st Century.
It's a very good book. Um it's very easy
to read and it's one of the most
discussed books right now.
And he makes the argument
he makes the argument why inequality
happens.
Inequality in society happens
because of the nature of capital.
Okay? The nature of money.
What money does is it seeks to grow for
the sake of growing.
And what's the best way for capital to
grow?
By consolidating
and charging rents.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, the the the example is, okay,
there were five restaurants in Beijing.
They could all start to compete against
each other for the for customers, right?
So, so they lower prices
and try to create better food.
But eventually, at some point, they
figure out, "Hey,
we're five restaurants, man. We can just
get together and negotiate a cartel, a
deal,
where we charge all the all high
prices."
Right?
Then we make more money that way. That's
something we call rent-seeking behavior,
rent-seeking.
The objective of rent-seeking is to
create a monopoly,
which forces
people to buy whatever prices you charge
them. Okay? That's the ultimate goal
of
of industry or society or business,
okay?
To engage in rent-seeking behavior.
And over time, because capital
consolidates,
it's much more profitable
to engage in capitalism than it is to
engage in entrepreneurship.
Meaning, you're better off actually
investing in stock market than you are
in
getting a job.
In fact,
what he shows is
the return on financial
capitalism is 5% a year. Okay, on
average, if you put $100 in the stock
market, you make $5.
All right?
But the return on the real economy
is only 2%.
Meaning, if you start up a factory and
you hire people, or you start up a
restaurant, which can which make which
contributes real growth, real wealthy
economy, you only make 2%.
All right?
And that's why
if you go to
America, and you will go to America
eventually,
you'll find that young people, your age,
they're not working. What are they
doing? They're investing in Bitcoin.
They're playing the stock the real
estate market.
They're
investing in stocks. Do you understand?
Because it's you make more money doing
that than you do by doing real work, by
creating a company.
You understand?
In other words,
your society
isn't producing any value.
And as a result, your economy can't move
on.
Right?
Does that make sense?
And when you're in this situation, what
are you forced to do now?
If you're if your society and and you
want to continue, what are you forced to
do?
Open economy.
Excuse me?
No. What do you do?
Historically, what what what have
societies done in order to get out of
this situation
where financialism
has destroyed your society?
Make war, guys.
Do you understand? When you make war,
you destroy things.
You destroy things, you're forced to
rebuild things.
It doesn't make sense.
That's why we have war.
Because war means a game reset.
It allows society to rebuild itself.
Okay? So, that's the first idea I want
you guys to understand. Over time
this is the economy matures to a point
where
everyone becomes a rent- renter, okay?
Or I'm sorry, a rentier.
You're trying to be a landlord, and
you're trying to charge people to use
your
land. You don't want to work.
This This is true throughout the world,
right? In China, it's the same thing
throughout Chinese history.
Right now in the West, it's the same
thing as well.
Okay?
And at that point, you have no choice
but to start a war to reset your
society.
Or your society will
continue to decline, okay? So, the first
boundary condition, why societies must
die.
Second boundary boundary condition is
the idea of rat utopia.
Okay. So, we discussed this a bit last
semester. I want to refresh your memory.
Rat utopia is an experiment that's been
done many times, but the idea is this.
What happens to rats in a perfect world?
Normally, rats have an extremely
ritual-less ritualized society.
So, for example, if you want to mate,
okay? What male rats do is they go on
top of a mound where all the female rats
can see them, right? And the rats, the
male rats, start to dance, okay? They
did that's really
like
um in a very strange way, but that
attracts the attention of the female.
The The male rat sees the attention of
the female rat, and the male rat starts
to chase the female rat. The female rat
runs back into her burrow, her home, and
hides.
The male rat has to stand outside and
wait for the female rat to come out.
Once she comes out,
she will start running again, and he
will start chasing
uh her.
And then she'll run back into her burrow
again. They do this multiple times until
eventually the female rat
lets
him catch her, and then they will have
sex, and they'll be married and have
children, okay? So, that's rat society.
It's no different from human society,
right?
You
like a girl, or you or or a boy, you
guys go out for a coffee date, then a
lunch date, then a dinner date, then
eventually, after a couple years, you
might have sex, and get married, and
have children, okay? No different. It's
a very heavily ritualized society.
What experimenters did was they asked
themselves, "What happen
if
we made a perfect world where no one had
to fight for food? Every day, food would
come down from the heavens, and all the
rats could do whatever they want. They
would have complete freedom." This is
what we call ratopia.
It turned out
all society collapsed. It was a complete
disaster.
The male rats start to rape female rats.
There's no more
like playing around. There's no more
ritual. It was all just rape and murder.
It was a complete breakdown of society.
Why did this happen?
Okay, there are many different theories,
but one thing that you need to
understand about rats and humans is we
all like status.
Status.
Okay? The idea is this.
We humans, we're all standing in line to
go on onto a mountain top, okay? The
mountain top, everyone respects you, you
make a lot of money, you feel good about
yourself.
And we're all standing in line.
And this line takes a long time, but
eventually you will get to the mountain
top.
This is How this game works is people at
the mountain top have to fall off and
die in order for other people to climb
up, okay? Does that make sense?
But, what happens when
the people at the mountain top don't
die?
Well, you're just stuck in line.
When you're stuck in line, I'm not sure
if you've been stuck in line for like
hours and hours, but you get angry,
right? You get frustrated. So, what do
you do? Well, you hit someone behind
you.
And then that person gets angry and hits
back hits you back, okay? Eventually,
that's this line, everyone's fighting
each other. And the people at the
mountain top are enjoying each other are
enjoying the view, they have status, and
they're never going to die. They're
never going to fall off. And this is our
society today, guys. Okay?
The people in power in in China, in the
United States, or in the world have been
there for a long, long time, and they're
not dying.
So, what are the young people doing?
Tang ping, bai lan, right?
Quiet quitting, lying flat. Because you
don't see any opportunities. What you
want is that money.
What you want
is status.
And that we that requires you to achieve
a certain level in society.
But,
those positions are being occupied by
people who refuse to die.
And as a result, society collapses.
Young people refuse to work, they refuse
to get married and have children. So,
your society dies.
You understand?
So, riot utopia is the second
boundary condition.
Does that make sense, guys? You're
seeing this around the world today, all
right? Ask yourselves, why is it that
you yourself are not motivated? And the
answer is, you really don't see an
opportunity
to climb to the top and enjoy status.
You just don't.
Because
people aren't dying. This is not. And
why? Because we've achieved a certain
level of abundance and wealth that
allows people to keep on living.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Any questions before I continue?
Are you guys clear about this?
And the third boundary condition
is the idea of elite overproduction.
What is elite overproduction?
Well, it's the same as riot utopia,
but
riot utopia is a conflict between the
haves and have-nots.
Elite overproduction is a conflict with
among the haves, okay? The very wealthy.
Because even though
there's a certain
number, a limited number, of status
positions,
too many elite people are being
produced.
Okay?
So, it's not only that the um
children of poor people are being
screwed over in the system, it's the
children of the elite are being screwed
over in the system.
And this creates conflict
in the system because the poor can't do
anything. They can just fight each other
in line, but the elite can do something.
They can go to war against each other.
They can monopolize They can start uh
killing each other, okay? This creates
civil war.
In fact,
if you are to look at
America today, you can say there's a
civil war going on between two different
factions of the elite.
Okay, does that make sense?
And this is what drives a lot of history
where
a lot of revolutions happen
not because
the poor are trying to overthrow the
rich, it's because
the low nobility
is fighting for opportunities against
the upper nobility.
Does that make sense, guys? Okay, and
we're seeing this again today in China
and also in
the United States.
All right? So, these are the three main
boundary conditions.
So, now let's apply to these three
boundary conditions
and ask ourselves why empires collapse.
Well, the first reason is
because most people in the empire
don't want to live there. They're just
stuck living there.
Why do most people don't want to live
there? Because they are in debt.
Okay?
Debt
and landlessness.
Throughout most of human history,
empires that have persisted for the
longest have this huge problem where the
majority of the population suffers from
too much debt and suffers from too much
landlessness, no opportunities.
Okay?
Then what happens is the elite starts
fighting amongst themselves. There's
corruption. Why is there corruption?
Because the elite are struggling
to
engage in rent-seeking behavior amongst
themselves. Okay, they're trying to
steal more they're stealing more and
more. So, there's corruption.
There's civil conflict and there's
corruption.
So,
it's only a matter of time before the
empire collapses.
But during this time, what does the
empire do?
Okay, it's really strange and funny, but
what they do is this.
They import
the people from the borderlands in order
to try to resolve their civil conflicts.
Okay, does that make sense?
You can't trust the army anymore because
the army is made up of people who have
too much debt and who are landless. So,
what do you do? You hire foreign
mercenaries.
Right? That's what China does. Or or
that's what China did in its history.
You can't trust your own army, so you
hire foreign mercenaries. And eventually
what happens is you replace your army
with foreign mercenaries.
And then
eventually, what happens? The foreign
mercenaries take over your empire.
That's what happened in Rome. That's
what happened
uh
throughout human history.
Okay?
Okay. So, now that we discuss the
empire, I want to look at the
borderlands.
Why is it true
that the borderlands
are able to conquer the empire?
And my argument to you is cultural.
Uh sorry, culture. It's cultural.
All right? So, we have this
prejudice or misunderstanding
about civilization.
All right? Civilization.
Civilization is about cities. It's about
writing. It's about technology. It's
about wealth.
And if you look at looked at it that
way,
then you don't really understand why is
it
these borderlands, the Mongolians, the
Manchu's,
the Vikings, the Arabians,
the Greeks, why are they able to conquer
these empires? That makes no sense to
you.
So, what I'm what I'm trying to say you
it what what what what I'm trying to
tell you is this is a wrong way of
looking at it. A better way of looking
at it is culture.
In the borderlands, there's a certain
culture that develops because it's the
borderlands. It's a It's a culture that
focuses on freedom,
egalitarianism,
and self-reliance.
Independence.
This is true throughout the borderlands,
okay?
If you If we were to go back to the to
Mongolia during the time of Genghis
Khan,
if we're If we were to go back to
the Germa- the European north of the
time of the Vikings,
these are cultures that emphasize
freedom, egalitarianism, and
self-reliance.
And as such,
these were
amazing warriors, okay?
So, let's let's look at an example.
Let's look at the
um
Vikings, okay?
The Vikings didn't know how to read or
write. They didn't have any mathematics.
They didn't have cities.
But from age two or three, their kids
were learning how to swim, how to row
boats, how to cook, how to hunt, how to
fight, how to ride horses.
Does that make sense?
And what what are
civilized kids doing? They're learning
how to do test questions.
Right? In a war, who's going to win?
Well, obviously these guys.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So, these are the This is the idea of
the oceanic currents, okay?
You have these
isolated areas
that are ecosystems amongst themselves.
As the empire expands, okay? Just think
of it as a current. You know, the
imperial current. It's just expanding,
expanding. That's all That's what
empires do. It energizes
these areas. And these areas actually
have much more energetic potential than
the empire, which is dying, okay?
And this energy
forces
so much energy in the borderlands that
they are now become like a hurricane,
and they have to ride through history.
Sometimes they're defeated, but
sometimes,
like the Greeks,
like the Vikings,
like the Mongolians,
like the Arabians,
they win.
And when they win,
they create a lot of destruction, okay?
And that's the idea I want you implant
in your head. These are
currents.
These are natural
forces that are unstoppable. Once they
start, you cannot stop them.
Okay? This war in Ukraine, it is a
hurricane that will engulf all of
Europe.
This war in the Middle East, it's a
hurricane that will engulf the entire
world. Once this starts, you can't have
a conference and decide to end it. It
These things cannot end until they reach
their natural course, okay?
The hurricane stops when it runs out of
energy.
Does that make sense?
The hurricane does not negotiate with
you and say, "Oh, well,
um you make a very good case for why I
shouldn't destroy you, so I'll just
stop."
Hurricanes don't do that.
Okay, these are natural forces.
Right? And this is what I will show you
this semester. And I I will also show
you how this connects to current events.
And then, once we do that, we should be
able to predict
current events.
And just plug in you know, spoiler
alert,
things will not end well.
Okay?
We are looking at the complete and utter
destruction of the world we live in
today.
Nothing will be the same.
Because these are
oceanic currents. They destroy
everything in its path.
Once you unleash them, they must
destroy.
It's only a question of how much.
Right?
All right.
Was this clear to you guys?
Any questions?
Anything you want to Any Any Anything
you want me to clarify or elaborate?
Again, I know this is a big theory, but
we will be doing a lot of examples
throughout the course of the semester.
All right? And this will give you a
unified theory of
history. And you'll see how everything
connects together.
Right?
Any questions?
So
So like,
do people who start these hurricanes
are
weather men people?
Oh, that's that's a good question, okay.
What starts these hurricanes or what
starts this process?
All right, so if you look at an ocean,
you will discover that these currents
are happening all the time.
You understand? There's There's no
start. They're always in motion.
All right? So, once you start an empire,
you're starting already to
unleash
a hurricane in the borderlands.
Once the hurricane matures in the
borderlands, it will overthrow an
empire, which will then start to
energize a new borderland.
Does that make sense?
So, that's a good That's a That's a
really good question. Uh and
unfortunately, the um the answer is
there'll always be a hurricane.
Hurricanes are always forming. You just
have to figure out where they're forming
in order to protect where where they're
coming from, okay?
But obviously, the two big hurricanes
right now are what's happening um in
Ukraine and what's happening in Israel
in the Middle East. Okay? But um other
hurricanes are are are coming, okay? Uh
for example,
there will eventually be a conflict in
East Asia.
All right? Now, a lot of people are
saying the conflict will be between um
China United States. I do not think
that's the case. I do not think
um the conflict will be between United
States and China. I think it will
involve Japan and South Korea.
All right? It will not be over the
Taiwan Strait. It will be between
It will involve South Korea and Japan.
How so, I don't really know, okay?
Another conflict is what's happening in
America.
America
um is itself a hurricane.
Eventually, America will have to fight a
civil war.
And when you go to America, you will see
how divided the country is.
All right? And people are already
predicting a civil war. It's only a
question of when. I think things will
speed up in 2028. The reason why is um
the election in 2028 will be heavily
contested.
People are going to argue over who won.
It'll be very unclear who won in 2028.
And there's a very good chance
Trump will run again in 2020.
Okay?
But I But I think these are two big
hurricanes that are coming along the
way. Not now, but they're coming along
the along the way.
Um this the big scary hurricane, of
course, is Iran.
Okay? Eventually, United States and Iran
will come to conflict with with each
other in will come to conflict with with
each other.
Okay? And this will drag in the entire
world.
Right? That That doesn't make sense to
you, Eva?
Okay. Thanks for the question. Okay. Any
more questions?
You mentioned that these currents never
end.
And so, when when when they force
continuously energize the
um borderlands, and they always
the currents always grow bigger and
bigger and
like
And so, it overwhelms the empire.
Yes. So so So, what's considered a
natural element, as
Like, how do they
run out of energy and
That That's a great question, okay.
All right. So, we have to figure out
what is driving the hurricane. And the
answer is the internal conflicts within
the borderlands.
Okay? Does that make sense? So, there's
just too many people. And there's just
not enough
status positions.
So, they go off and they conquer their
own territory, right? So, if you look at
the Vikings, okay, the Vikings. The
Vikings are interesting. The Vikings,
which we'll discuss a lot, they're in
northern Europe. And for most of human
history, we had actually no idea they
were there, okay? They were in the north
in Den- mark, in Norway, and Sweden. And
they basically kept to themselves. They
still traded with the world, but we
didn't really know know much about them,
okay? And then they started to come out
of nowhere.
And they did three things. They went
over to colonize Greenland and Iceland.
All right? And they also went to
actually North America. So, they were
actually the first Europeans to reach
North America.
So, one trait that trait that they had
was to expand and explore and colonize,
okay?
But then you also had a group of
Vikings, Northmen, who went to attack
France.
And they were so such a huge problem
that the French decided to give them
their own land called Normandy.
Okay? Normandy, the land of the North
people, Normandy.
All right?
And then they went over here to Ukraine
uh along the Dnieper uh uh
river because they were trading
with
the Islamic Empire.
And they founded colonies or new new
settlements. And this was a peaceful
process.
Okay? Because they were trying to
establish
trading posts.
And this became the basis of which
country do you guys know?
Russia.
Okay?
Because these people were called the
Rus.
I actually don't know what Rus means,
but it just means Rus. And that's where
Russia comes from.
So, this is the beginning of a new
country called Russia.
All right? And Normandy is interesting
because they eventually went off to
conquer a new country called Do you guys
know?
Who they conquered? The Who who who did
the Nor- Normans conquer?
1066, guys.
England.
Britain.
All right? You understand?
So, the Hurkens stop stops when
the people just run out of energy
because they've reached a point where
they can't go on, okay?
The Hurken create is created because
they have wealth, power, but they don't
have enough status
positions.
So, that they expand to fill these
status positions, okay? This is This is
actually what drives empire building.
Does that make sense?
It's not because you lack resources,
it's because you have too many people
who want status and you can't fill fill
them you can't let leave them in society
because then they will overthrow you.
So, you send them somewhere else, okay?
All right?
Good. Is is that clear, Echo?
Great. Any more questions?
Great. Okay. So, uh I I hope this was
clear.
We will continue
discussing this throughout the
throughout the semester because this
becomes a framework for which you
understand all of European history for
the past 3,000 years, okay? So, next
class we will do the Roman Empire, the
fall and decline of the Roman Empire,
which will lead us into the rise of
something called the Holy Roman Empire,
which is not the Roman Empire, okay?
It's basically the French Empire.
Okay, or the um Frankish Empire.
And the Frankish Empire will lead to the
rise of the Vikings.
All right?
All right. So, those are the next three
classes.
All right.
Great.